within kanto um you celebrated the
hispanic family and generational trauma
was kind of a major theme yeah well it's
funny i remember talking to you i think
the week before it came out dude
i love you so much you're so talented i
don't i don't think you know a person
that's seen that movie more than myself
because of my kids like i remember i
remember the week before it came out
also i i did your show and i met someone
and his name was bruno
and i said
you're not gonna understand
but i'm so sorry
i'm just i'm just remember i said i'm
sorry
in advance it's like any girl named
jolene yeah jolie
eliza's i am sorry
i love that that's hysterical but but
speaking of encanto um is it true that
bruno originally had a different name
yeah bruno in the early drafts was named
oscar
i can't hear that now yeah well
oscar kirk
and then they found out that oscar
magical was like a super common name or
like a taken name in colombia and so
they they gave me like three other
finalists and as soon as i saw bruno i
was like got it yeah i got the whole
song yeah i got bruno and i can play
with the no no no and i'm done yeah
thank you for writing this song for me
this is a great vow to sing really yeah
i like to change those up sometimes and
they're like that's not how you
pronounce it i don't care
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
i'm going home
[Music]